I am Surma I am a developer advocate for
the open web platform and work for with
a chrome team for Google in London and I
have the great pleasure today talk about
one of my newly found passions which is
web assembly you have probably heard of
it a bit a little bit and you can
contact me on Twitter if you have any
questions in the future and later on my
colleague deeply from the web
engineering team is gonna talk a bit
about the future of web assembly um
before we start though I wanted to bring
us all onto the same page because web
assembly is often associated very
tightly with c+ nuts so much so that a
lot of people think it is all about C++
when in fact web assembly is so much
more than that many of the demos that
you can find online are about C++ and M
scripting and that makes sense because M
strippin is an absolutely amazing tool
but it is very important for web
developers to realize that it's not just
this worthless and that web assembly by
itself is actually a really useful tool
to have in your back pocket and that's
what I want to talk about in this talk I
want to show some other languages that
support web assembly how you can use web
assembly maybe without learning a new
language and then as I said Deepti it's
going to talk a bit about what the
future of web assembly might hold so to
just make sure everybody knows what
we're here for
this is what assembly dot-org where we
can explain what web assembly is it is a
stack based virtual machine and if you
don't know what a web stack based
virtual machine is that is absolutely
okay what is important though is that
you realize it is a virtual machine
meaning it's a processor that doesn't
really exist but something that has been
designed to easily compile to a lot of
actual real architectural and that it's
called portability so it is a virtual
machine designed to prioritize
portability so when you write some code
in whatever language and you compile it
to web assembly
that code will get compiled to the
instruction set of that virtual machine
and then that those instructions get
stored in a binary code binary format
usually in a dot wasm file and because
that virtual machine is designed to
easily compile to real processors this
file can now be ingested by a runtime
which in our context here is most likely
the browser the browser can turn that
Watson file into actual machine code of
the actual machine the browser's running
on and then execute that code and from
the very start web assembly was designed
to make that process secure so yes you
are running code on your bare metal but
it's not an insecure thing we already
talked about web assembly at the last
i/o actually quite a bit it's a
technology that's growing super quickly
in actual ocean maturing at a very
impressive pace and we talked about how
some big companies are using web
assembly to bring their existing
products that they probably wrote in C++
for example to the web so for example
that was AutoCAD who had been working on
AutoCAD for years and it's a well known
product but now they put in the effort
of compiling it to web assembly and
suddenly it was running in the browser
which is kind of mind-blowing when you
think about it another example would be
the Unity game engine or the Unreal game
engine which now support web assembly so
these game engines often already have a
kind of abstraction built in because you
build your game and then you compile it
to a Playstation or to Xbox or other
systems but now what assembly is just
another target and what is impressive is
that the browser and web assembly are
able to deliver the performance
necessary to run these kind of games and
I find that amazing and these things are
going to continue to happen so you have
already seen in the web keynote that my
colleague Paul Lewis built an inception
at perception toolkits which helps you
build kind of immersive experiences and
they wanted to build links into the real
worlds in the form of QR codes and image
detection so QR codes can already be
detected by browsers using the shape
detection API but not every browser has
that in
clementa so what they're doing is
they're using that shape detection API
but if it's not available they have
cross-compiled zebra crossing a QR code
library to web assembly and load that on
demand to fill the gap if they find it
and image detection isn't on the web at
all so they build that themselves and
used web assembly to give a new
capability to a browser the UI toolkit
QT announced that they're also
supporting web assembly now so that kind
of means that you can now actually take
an old Lib QT app and compile it to web
assembly and then you have this weird
window in a browser tab experience which
is not ideal but it just shows how it
works but lip Qt it's a very powerful
and generic UI library so there's loads
of demos on the website at the bottom
where they actually build kind of good
and native looking UI using lip beauty
and web assembly so if you don't know
that much about web assembly you might
be asking how did they do that and the
answer in these cases is em scripting em
strips goal is to be a drop-in
replacement for your C or C++ compiler
and instead of compiling to your machine
code it spits out web assembly and they
really try to be a drop-in replacements
whatever code you wrote to run on a
system should just magically run on the
web and that's very important as a
distinction to make because M scripting
does a lot of heavy lifting behind the
scenes to make that happen
and I think because it worked so it
works so well in these scenarios is why
it is so tightly associated with web
assembly currently because originally M
stripping was an Adam J's compiler this
was an idea by Mozilla where they wrote
this compiler that takes C code and
turns it into a JavaScript so what you
see on the right is Adam J's it's just
normal JavaScript and every browser that
can execute JavaScript can execute Adam
Jess but the plan was to give some
browsers and understanding of S&J so
that they have a dedicated fast path to
make these kind of programs run faster
so to have a chunk of memory and you
have some variables and
your C++ code can run in your JavaScript
engine but C and C laws often use other
api's like file opening and maybe OpenGL
so M scripting made that work by using
WebGL to pretend to be OpenGL and to
emulate a file system so you can pretend
to be working on real files
so they're basically emulating an entire
POSIX operating system to make code run
on the web that was never written for
the web so they hacked made that happen
so when webassembly came along M
scripting just added a new output format
but kept all the work they had put into
making that emulation so amis Krypton
was basically able to use all the
experience that they had with you know
making POSIX code work on the web and
apply to web assemblies so they were
able to extremely fast deliver extremely
impressive and actually mature demos and
tools around web assembly and they
deserve a lot of credit for taking
everybody along with him and leveling
out the playing field for all the other
languages that have come along since and
I think that's why web assembly is so
tightly so he was you know that's
because of that quick maturity of M
scripting but what about web developers
how about you who might be working at a
web agency or maybe even a freelance
developer how can M how can webassembly
be useful to you do you have to learn
C++
spoiler alert know when you are a web
developer and you think oh I should
learn C++ so I can use web assembly many
people end up like this because what
even is C++ when you know JavaScript and
fun fact it works the other way around
as well when I see a C++ developer see
or write JavaScript for the first time
they make the exact same face and I'm
not saying that because one language is
better than the other but just because
they requires such a drastically
different mindset to write I have
written both professionally and whenever
I switch I'm eye twitch a little bit
sometime is just very different to think
about what I'm saying is there was so
far no incentive for a web developer to
learn C++ and so the amount of people
who are comfortable in both worlds is
fairly small and as a result web
assembly seemed like a very niche
technology when in fact it's actually a
really useful tool to have in your back
pocket and so what I want to talk about
it's the two main use case that I
usually see when I think about web
assembly on the one hand I want to talk
about the surgical replacement of tiny
modules in your JavaScript app the hot
pass the bottlenecks with web assembly
and want to talk about the myth that web
assembly is faster than JavaScript but
first I want to talk about the other
facet about ecosystems it might seem a
bit weird because nobody will probably
disagree when I say that the JavaScript
ecosystem is pretty huge I mean just
look at NPM it's massive but it's just a
fact that not every topic not for every
topic JavaScript is the first choice
while other languages might be so
sometimes you're faced with a problem
and you're looking for libraries to
solve these problems and you find them
in C or in rust but not in JavaScript so
you can either sit down and write your
own JavaScript port or your new option
is to tap into another languages
ecosystem using web assembly and that's
exactly what we did with Scrooged
Scrooged is an image compression app
that runs completely in the browser and
offline no server-side and you can drop
in images and you can compress them with
different codecs and then visually
inspect how these different codecs have
different effects on the visual quality
of your image now the browser already
offers that if you know because with
canvas you can decide in what image
formats you want to encode an image and
he even gets control over the quality
but it turns out that these codecs by
the browser are optimized for
compression speed rather than
compression quality or visual quality
so that was a bit lackluster to be
honest and also you're kind of bound to
the codecs that the browser supports so
until recently only chrome caught encode
to web P and none of the other browsers
so that wasn't enough for us and so we
googled the bid and we found some codec
encoders for JPEG written in JavaScript
but there were kind of weird and also we
didn't find the single encoder in
JavaScript for web P so we thought we
have to look at something else and we
found loads of encoders in C and C++
so web assembly so what we did is we
compiled for example the the library
called mods JPEG in to web assembly
loaded in the browser and replaced the
browser's JPEG encoder with our own and
what that allowed us is that we actually
got much smaller images at the same
visual quality setting which is kind of
cool but not only that it only also
allowed us to expose loads of expert
options that the library had but that
the browser obviously didn't expose so
things like configuring the chroma
subsampling or different quantization
algorithms are not only valuable to
squeeze out the last couple bites from
an image but also just as a learning
tool to see how these options actually
affect your image visually and the file
size the point here really is that we
took an old piece of code Mott's JPEG
goes back to like 1991 with it was
written definitely not with a weapon
mind but we're using it on the web
anyway and using it to improve the web
platform and we used em scripting so
with M scripting to show you how that
works I usually find myself in a two
step process the first step is compiling
the library something that you can link
against later often image codecs make
use of threads and Sandy because image
compression is a highly parallelizable
task but neither JavaScript nor
webassembly have support for threats or
simply just yet simply deepti we'll talk
about that a bit later what is coming on
that front but for now we disable sim D
to make
sure we don't run into any problems and
in the second step you have to write a
piece of what I call bridge code this is
the function that I want to call from
JavaScript later on so it takes the
image it takes the image dimensions and
then use a small JPEG to compress it and
returns a typed array buffer which
contains the JPEG image and once you
have written this bridge code we call
EMC cm strip and C compiler with our C++
file and the library file link it all
together and provide it I didn't make
any mistakes we get this output a
JavaScript file that sets everything up
for us and the web assembly file now
here is something to keep in mind
because M stripping is a drop-in
replacement and does all these emulation
and all that heavy lifting for you it is
always a good idea to keep an eye on
your file sizes because these kind of
file system emulations and API tunneling
that's code that needs to get shipped so
if you use all of C api's these files
can become quite big especially the
JavaScript file we have been working
with the M scripting team quite
intensely to help them keep it at a
minimum but there's only so much you can
do if you want to be a drop-in
replacement so keep an eye on your file
sizes another example of web assembly in
Skoosh is image scaling because it turns
out making an image bigger or smaller
there's many ways to achieve that with
many different visual effects and visual
outputs so with the browser if you just
use the browser to scale an image you
just get what you get it will probably
be fast it will probably look good but
sometimes having control over the
different variants of scaling an image
can really make a big visual impact so
on this video you can see me switching
back and forth between the lengths or
three algorithm and whatever the browser
has and you can see that with length of
three I actually have and linear RGB
color space conversion I actually have a
much more real perception of brightness
in this picture so in this case it's
actually a really valuable piece of code
to have running so this image these
image scaling algorithms that we are
using in Skoosh we actually took from
the
rust ecosystem Mozilla has been heavily
investing in the rust ecosystem and
their team writes web web assembly tools
for rust but the community also
abstracts those away to just generic
tools one of these tools is poison pack
which really takes you by the hand and
generate turns your rust code into web
assembly modules a modern JavaScript and
really small and I think it's really fun
to play around with
so with rust same kind of principle we
have a library and we want to write our
little bridge code so in this case the
resize function is what I want to call
from JavaScript it takes the image and
my input size and the output size and
then I just return the resized image
afterwards and then you use weapon pack
to just turn all of that into a web
assembly module that you can use now the
size comparison is not quite fair
because it's a different library and
it's a smaller library so don't compare
it byte by byte but on average Rus tends
to generate much smaller glue code which
kind of makes sense because Rus doesn't
do anything of the POSIX filesystem
emulation you can't use a file function
and rust because it doesn't do
filesystem emulation they have some
crates that you can pull in if you want
to have that but it's much more of an
opt-in approach so the bottom line is
that with squash we are using four
different libraries at least from two
different languages that have nothing to
do with the web but we still proceeded
to use them on the web and that's really
what I want you to take home from this
entire thing is that if you find a gap
in the web platform and has been filled
many times in another language but not
on the web or not in JavaScript web
assembly might be a tool but now let's
talk about the surgical replacement of
hot paths in your JavaScript and the
mists that Java web assembly is faster
than JavaScript now that's it's really
important to me and that's why I came up
with this really far-fetched visual
metaphor both javascript and web
assembly
half the same peak performance they are
equally fast but it is much easier to
stay on the fast path with webassembly
than it is with JavaScript or the other
way around it is way too easy sometimes
to unknowingly and unintentionally end
up in a slow path in your JavaScript
engine than it is in the web assembly
engine now that being said web assembly
is looking into shipping threads and
Cindy thinks that javascript will never
get access to so s once these things
ship web assembly will have a chance to
actually outperform JavaScript quite a
bit but at the current state of things
the peak performance is the same to
understand how this whole falling off
the fast path happens let's talk a bit
about v8 Chrome's
JavaScript and web assembly engine
javascript files and web assembly files
have two different entry points to the
engine javascript files get passed to
ignition which is v8 interpreter so it
reads the javascript file as text and
interprets it and runs it while it's
running it it collects analytics data
about what how the code is behaving and
that is then being used by turbofan the
optimizing compiler to generate machine
code web assembly on the other hand gets
passed to liftoff the streaming web
assembly compiler and once that compiler
is done turbofan kicks in and generates
optimising codes now there's some
differences here the first obvious
difference is that the first stage has a
different name and a different logo but
there's also a conceptual difference
ignition is an interpreter and liftoff
is a compiler that generates machine
codes so it would be an
overgeneralization to say that machine
code is always fastened interpreted code
but on average it's probably true so
here's our we the first difference in
terms of speed perception but more
importantly is this difference for
JavaScript the optimizing compiler only
kicks in eventually this code has to run
and be observed before can be optimized
because certain assumptions are made
from the observations machine
coal is generated and then the machine
code is running but once these
assumptions don't hold anymore you have
to fall back to the interpreter because
we can't guarantee that the machine code
does the right thing anymore and that's
called a deopt ad optimization with
webassembly turbofan always kicks in
right after the lift of compiler and you
always stay on the lift off on the
turbofan outputs you always stay on the
fast path and you can never get D
updates and I think that's where the the
misconception comes from that web
assembly is faster you just always get
you can easier get D opted in Java you
cannot and web assembly and Nick
Fitzgerald from the rust web assembly
team actually did a really nice
benchmark that he wrote a benchmark in
both JavaScript and web assembly
JavaScript is read web assembly is blue
and run it in different browsers and
what you can see here is yes okay web
assembly is faster but the main takeaway
really here is that JavaScript has to
spread it is kind of unpredictable in
what how long it takes while web
assembly is like spot-on always the same
time even across browsers and I think
that is really the the key line I would
like you to take home with you web
assembly gives you more predictable
performance it delivers more predictable
performance than JavaScript and that's
actually a story I can tell as well in
from Skoosh we wanted to rotate an image
so we thought okay let's use canvas but
we couldn't because canvas is on the
main thread off-screen canvas was barely
in chrome at that point so we actually
ended up writing a piece of JavaScript
by hand to rotate it or just reorder the
pixels to rotate the image and it worked
really well it was very fast but it
turns out the more we tested in other
browsers the more it became a bit weird
so in the test case we were rotating a
4k by 4k image and this is not about
comparing browsers this is about
comparing JavaScript the fastest browser
took 400 milliseconds the slowest
browser took 8 seconds even of the main
thread that's way too long for a user
pressing a button to rotate an image and
so what you can see here really
that will clearly stayed on the fast
path in one browser but we fell off the
fast path in another and the browser
wasn't usually a fast browser just some
browsers optimized differently and so we
wrote our rotate code in web assembly or
in couple of languages that compile to
web assembly to compare how the performs
and what you can see here that pretty
much all the web assembly languages
bring us somewhere around the 500
millisecond mark I would call that
predictable I mean there's still a bit
of variance but nothing compared to the
variants of JavaScript and that's a
logarithmic scale and so if and also
what you can see here I just noticed is
that there had to had performance of
webassembly the peak performance of web
attempt in JavaScript it's pretty much
the same so if you look at the graph you
might be wondering what assembly script
is and if you haven't I'm really excited
about this because assembly script
really brings me back to the title of my
talk which is web assembly for web
developers assembly script is a type
script to webassembly compiler now it
that might mislead you because you can't
just throw your existing typescript at
this compiler and get web assembly out
of it because in webassembly you don't
have Dom API so that you can't just use
the same code but what they're using is
the typescript syntax with a different
type library so that means you don't
have to learn a new language to write
web assembly which i think is kind of
amazing
so what it looks like it's like
typescript just with a couple of my new
differences in that something like a 32
it's not a type that JavaScript has but
it is a type that web assembly has and
then there are these built-in functions
like load and store that put values onto
the memory or read them from memory and
the assembly script compiler turns those
into web assembly modules so you are now
able to write web assembly without
learning a new language and benefit all
and harness all these benefits that
webassembly might offer to you and I
think that's kind of powerful something
to keep in mind is that unlike
typescript webassembly doesn't have a
garbage collector at least
yet and Deepti we'll talk about this a
bit more later so at least for now you
have to do memory management yourself so
assembly script offer us a couple of
memory management module so you can just
pull in and then you have to do these C
style allocations it's something to get
used to a bit but it's very much usable
right now and once webassembly does get
garbage collection it could get even
better so that's one of like
full-disclosure assembly script is a
fairly young and small project it has a
group of extremely passionate people
behind it it has a couple of sponsors
but nothing compared to like Mozilla
behind rust or M script and that all
being said it is absolutely usable and
very enjoyable my colleague Erin Turner
wrote an entire emulator in assembly
scripts and so if you're injured in that
you should look him up on github and
take a look at the code now one thing
that I want to make sure that I say out
loud is at the current state of affairs
putting everything in wasm is not a good
idea
Java code and webassembly are not
opponents there's synergy between them
use them together one doesn't replace
the other like debugging is going to be
harder and shunko spitting it's much
harder with webassembly currently than
it is with JavaScript and you have to
call back and forth like it's just not
gonna be a great experience I had some
people treated me that they want to
write their web components and sleeves
last class I don't know why they would
want to do that but apparently they want
to do that but I wouldn't recommend it
what I would like to say is web assembly
the right things do some performance
audits do measurements where are your
bottlenecks and see if webassembly can
help you do you fight did you find a gap
in the platform and you can fill it from
a different language again web assembly
is your tool but now to talk a bit about
the future of web assembly and the
upcoming feature I would like to welcome
Deepti to the stage
thanks Irma hi everyone I'm DP I'm a
software engineer on the chrome team and
I work on standardizing webassembly
features as well as implementing them in
v8
okay sorry about that so most of it
you've seen in this presentation so far
has landed and shipped in all major
browsers which is the MVP or the minimum
viable product of web assembly and we've
been working hard and adding
capabilities to make sure that we get
closer and closer to native performance
the MVP itself unlocks a whole set of
new applications on the web but this is
not the end goal and there are a lot of
new exciting features that the community
group and the implementers are working
to enable the first one of these is the
web sandy threats proposal the threading
proposal introduces primitives for
parallel computation concretely that
means that it introduces the concept of
a shared linear memory between threads
and semantics for atomic instructions
now why is this necessary the many
existing libraries that are written in C
or C++ that use P threads and those can
be compiled to wasm and run in
multi-threaded mode allowing different
threads to work on the same data in
parallel aside from just enabling new
capabilities for applications that
benefit from multi-threaded execution
you would see performance scale with the
number of threads so the threading
proposal builds on primitives that
already exists in the web platform the
web has support for multi-threaded
execution
using web workers and that's exactly
what's used to introduce multi-threaded
execution to web to web assembly the
downside of web workers is that they
don't share mutable data between them
instead they rely on message passing for
communication through post message so if
so they'd rely on message passing for
communication so each of these
webassembly threads
runs in a web worker but their shared
web assembly memory allows them to work
work on the same data and making them
run close to native speeds the shared
linear memory here is built on the
shared array buffer so if you look at
this diagram each of these threads is
running in a web worker and can have a
web assembly in
that instantiate it with the same linear
memory this means that the instances
operate on the shared memory but have
their own separate execution stacks so
the API to create a web based on the
memory remains almost the same if you
look at the first line there the you
create a web assembly memory with a
shared flag and a mandatory maximum this
creates a shared way before underneath
with the initial size that we've
specified there which is one page of
memory so with all of these threads
operating on the same memory how do we
ensure that the data is consistent
atomic modifications allow us to perform
some level of synchronization so when a
thread performance and atomic operation
the other thread see it as happening
instantaneously but full synchronization
often requires actual blocking of a
thread until another is finished
executing so the proposal has an example
of mutex
implementation and I pull it of how you
would use this in a JavaScript host if
you look at it closely there's subtle
differences between what you would do in
a worker was versus what you would do on
the main thread so on the main thread
the try lock mutex method is called
which tries to lock a mutex at the given
address it returns 1 if the mutex is
successfully locked or 0 otherwise
and on the worker thread it will lock a
mutex at the given address retrying
until it's successful so basically why
this is the way it is is that on the web
you can't actually block the main thread
and this is something that's useful to
keep in mind when using the threading
primitives so what is the current status
of this proposal the proposal itself is
fairly stable but there's ongoing work
to formalize the memory model that's
used by the shared array buffer the
thing I'm really excited about here is
that this is shipped in chrome 74 and is
on by default so Surma mentioned QT
earlier in the presentation and QT use
full threat support so this is something
that you can use in your applications
today as the shared memory primitive
here is the JavaScript shared away
buffer and that's temporarily disabled
on some browsers webassembly threads is
not currently available by default on
all browsers but you can still try this
out in Firefox nightly behind the flag
one of the goals of web assembly is to
be a low-level abstraction over modern
hardware this is especially true of the
webOS and AMD proposal cindy is shot for
single instruction multiple data it lets
one instruction operate at the same time
on multiple data items so most modern
CPUs support some subset of vector
operations so that this proposal is
trying to take advantage of capabilities
that already exist in hardware that you
use everyday the challenge here is to
find a subset that is well supported on
most architectures but also is still
performing currently this subset is
limited to 128 bits MD there are a
couple of different ways to use this MD
proposal by using Auto vectorization you
can pass in a flag to enable sim D while
compiling and the compiler would Auto
vectorize your program for you on the
other hand many simply use cases our
niche and highly tuned for performance
and use hand-coded assembly so these
would be using clang built-ins or
intrinsics that generate machine code
that is tuned for performance now assume
D can be used for a large variety of
applications so you can use it for image
or audio video codecs applications like
Google Earth and Photoshop or even
machine learning applications on the web
we've had a lot of interest for web ml
and SEM D collaborations as well so
let's take a closer look at how this
data is operated on here you see a
simple example of an add instruction on
an array let's say this is an array of
integer values so this on the left side
is what a scaler operation would look
like
where you add each number to the other
and store the result the vector version
of this would just boil down to one
hardware instruction for example a P ad
or repiy ad on some Intel architectures
so simply operations work by allowing
multiple pieces of data to be packed
into one data word and enabling the
instruction to act on each piece of data
this is useful for cases where the same
operation has to be performed on large
amounts of data for example take image
processing c1 a compress an image in
Skoosh or reduce the amount of color of
an image in Photoshop by half the
assembly operations would actually make
this a lot more performant so we've
talked about making use of underlying
hardware capabilities and always
capabilities to make your applications
performance now let's look at what
happens on the other side what what are
we doing for better interrupt with the
hosts one of the proposals that's being
implemented by multiple browsers is the
reference types proposal but the
reference type proposal web assembly
code can pass around arbitrary
JavaScript values using the any ref
value type these values are opaque to
web assembly but by importing JavaScript
built-in functions web assembly modules
can perform many fundamental JavaScript
operations without actually requiring
JavaScript glue code so the web assembly
table object is a structure that stores
function references at a high level so
this reference types proposal also adds
some table instruction for manipulation
of tables inside of wasone the neat
thing about this is that the reference
types proposal is actually setting up
setting the stage for really useful
future proposals so for efficient
interrupts with the host for the web
ideal proposal or exception references
for exception handling and it also
enables a smoother part to having
garbage collection and I'll be talking
about all of this in the next few slides
so a proposal that our team will be
focusing on
in the near future is a web IDL bindings
proposal web idea is an interface
definition language and it can be used
to define interfaces that are
implemented in the web we touched on
this a little bit with the reference
types the basic idea here is that this
proposal describes adding a new
mechanism to represent 3/4 avoiding
unnecessary overhead when calling or
being called through the web IDL
interface the web idea bindings proposal
would allow compilers to optimize calls
from web assembly into existing web
api's and browser environments today as
well as other api's and that may use web
IDL in the future so let's take a closer
look at this so when you have a wasm
function you you would call this call a
javascript through the Jas API the jsapi
goes through the binding layer that
facilitates communication between the
jsapi and the web api is for Dom access
this adds a lot of glue code and
additional overhead the goal of the web
aerial bindings proposal is to reduce
this overhead and optimize calls from
web assembly into existing web api's so
effectively this would not have to go
through the jsapi and the bindings would
also be optimized to reduce the overhead
so you would have streamlined calls
between web assembly and web api x' so
currently when we talked about CC plus
rush and putting these languages to web
assembly is very well supported and
there's a lot of work on going to bring
different classes of other languages to
the web one such feature is garbage
collection which is necessary for
efficient support of high-level
languages that means faster execution
smaller modules and outside of c c++
this is really a requirement for being
able to support a vast my write a vast
majority of modern languages this is
also a large and open-ended problem but
we've been making progress by carving
out smaller proposals and
and the exact design constraints so
currently wasn't designed explicitly
forbids tail call optimization in the
future we want to enable correct and
efficient air call implementations of
languages that require tail collar
emulations so these would be functional
languages like Haskell we ate already
has an implementation for this and this
is actually moving along quite well so
for full C++ support we need exception
handling in a web environment exception
handling can be emulated using
JavaScript exception handling which can
provide the correct semantics but really
isn't fast so post MVP web assembly will
gain support for zero cost exception
handling and this is something that is
being actively worked on as well we're
also working on a number of other
proposals so feel free to check out the
future features documentation on the web
assembly github page the other thing I
want I want to emphasize is that a lot
of these are in the design phase and if
you're interested in wanting to
participate all of the development is
done in an open community group so
contributions are always welcome we also
talked about performance so if you have
performance bottlenecks and you've used
wasm - you know elevate some of the
concerns we'd love to hear from you
Irma and I are going to be hanging out
here and later in the web stand bug so
if you have questions please come find
us there or obviously find us online
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]